the Loki season 2 finale was epic it was
perfect the story arc for Loki in the
MCU going from the first Thor film to
The Avengers film to now from the god of
Mischief to the protector of the literal
Multiverse could be the best Arc that we
have ever seen in the MCU but what
exactly did that finale mean what
specifically does it mean for the
Multiverse for Loki what specifically is
Loki doing we've explained this in a few
videos how however Marvel Studios has
finally come out and basically told us
exactly what it means now a lot of you
have thought Loki god of stories we've
talked about this as well and as it
turns out we were only half right Marvel
Studios acknowledges that this is Loki
god of stories here at the finale of
season 2 for Loki but it's also not and
this may sound confusing but it's
actually not Marvel Studios puts it in a
really really great way that makes you
respect Loki even more so let's break
down what they said said but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the recent MCU
videos and if you subscribe and leave a
comment down below you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner gets to pick one item and we pick
one winner at the end of each month so
if you are unaware Aaron Morehead was
the director for Loki season 2 and he
was recently on the phase zero podcast
from comicbook.com talking about the
Loki finale specifically and he talks
about
the actual god Loki from Norse mythology
not from Marvel Comics but from Norse
mythology which is really cool and they
explain that Loki doesn't really just
become the god of stories he becomes the
god of everyone's story I'll explain in
more detail in just a bit but basically
in the comics Loki the god of stories
can do anything he want he could write
anything into existence past present or
future if he wrote a story it became
true hence Loki god of stories and this
was on Marvel Marv studios's mind from
the very beginning according to Aaron
Morehead this is what he said in the
podcast one of the early days
discussions about how we're going to be
treating the entire final episode
especially the last half of the final
episode we were actually looking at the
Wikipedia for Loki not the comic book
character but the actual God and he was
the god of stories and when we looked up
at the Whiteboard that Tom and Kevin
Wright the producer brought us into to
see it had written God of stories it was
just a little note somewhere and we
really really latched on to that and so
we feel like somebody who is the god of
Mischief he's the god of chaos and
trickery and all that he's transformed
into I wouldn't even say god of time I
would say he's the god of everyone's
story and he's a librarian that protects
it and allows it to flourish so this is
really really interesting and is
actually another characteristic that
makes you love Loki even more when you
hear this real explained Loki
essentially did become he who remains he
is the god of stories he could rewrite
anything which is his power in the
comics he could rewrite any existing
event that had happened in the Marvel
Comics Universe changing the past
therefore changing the future this is
what Kang did essentially he would
interfere with the timelines to make it
exactly as he wanted it to plus as he
mentioned several times he wrote the
final story he wrote everything
including all of season 2 for Loki and
Loki ending up back there at the Citadel
at the end of time so essentially he who
remains kind of had that power but now
Loki has it but there is one key
difference here Loki is actually truly
good now so he doesn't use his power to
rewrite time but instead he protects it
he is protecting every single person in
the Multiverse and it comes back down to
what him and Sylvie were saying from the
very beginning in Loki season 1 it's all
about Free Will Loki was in pursuit of
Free Will from the beginning and now he
is the protector of Free Will sitting at
the center of the Multiverse protecting
it which is what Aaron Morehead says
here but it's even more impressive for
Loki if you think about a few key things
and we'll get to that in just a bit but
first big thank you to Highland titles
for sponsoring this video before we leap
back into the world of superpowers got
something truly extraordinary for our
Noble listeners imagine that you yes you
can become a lord or lady for just $30
buying a plot of land from Highland
titles .c will allow you to make use of
a Scottish tradition in which land
owners are given a courtesy title with
more than 15,000 five-star reviews the
Highland titles gift pack is an
incredibly popular gift and the Highland
titles app available from the app and
play stores is a new addition that
allows you to explore a 3D replica of
the land choose the location of your
plot and decorate it using augmented
reality embrace the Majesty as every
purchase helps to conserve the a
inspiring heroic beauty of the Scottish
Wilderness you can soar into the world
of nobility My Friends by visiting
Highland ti.com and become a lord or
lady today use the discount code Cosmic
to receive 25% off your order that's
Highland ties.com and use code Cosmic so
if you truly want to understand how far
Loki has come if you truly want to
understand the power that he has now but
also his character now the essence of
who he is now and how much he has
changed and how benevolent he is now we
have to go back to the very first
Avengers film right before Iron Man and
Captain America show up Loki has a group
of people in public kneeling because he
tells them to kneel and he gives the big
Loki speech most of us know it he says
is not this simpler is this not your
natural state it's the unspoken truth of
humanity that you crave subjugation the
bright lure of Freedom diminishes your
life's joy in a mad Scramble for power
your identity you were made to be ruled
in the end you will always kneel this is
Loki in the first Avengers film this is
the complete opposite of what Loki did
for the entire Multiverse in the season
finale for season 2 in the end which is
kind of Loki now he is kind of the god
of time now even Marvel Studios
basically states that but in the end
nobody will kneel and it's all because
Loki chooses that for the Multiverse he
actually sacrif IES himself so that
nobody will have to kneel and what is
very interesting is that line of Loki
being the god of time where Aaron
Morehead says I wouldn't even say the
god of time I would say he's the god of
everyone's story and he's a librarian
that protects it and allows it to
flourish the protects it and allows it
to flourish part kind of refers to two
different things one is Kang and all the
variants of Nathaniel Richards AKA Kang
he is proteced it from Kang however the
TVA is doing most of that work what Loki
did was enable the Multiverse to exist
he empowers it he gives it life and he
made sure he who remains was dead so
that he could not interfere and only
make one sacred timeline but the
Multiverse could actually exist however
there's another part to this he is also
protecting it from himself Loki if he
wanted to could do whatever he wanted to
with the Multiverse he could literally
be the god of stories rewrite everything
to exactly how he wanted it to just like
he who remains did so obviously he's not
doing that the whole point was for
everybody to have free will but if Loki
wanted to he could become the actual God
of stories and change everything when
Aaron Morehead says I wouldn't even say
the god of time that kind of means he
could be called that but instead they'd
rather call him a librarian that
protects the Multiverse and allows it to
flourish but basically that is saying
you could call him the god of time
because he can control all of time
literally in every Multiverse and I
think this is going to come into play in
a pretty big way when we get to Avengers
Secret Wars and the Multiverse actually
is falling apart because remember now
how Loki is protecting the universe is
literally giving everybody Free Will
he's not going to interfere he is
protecting that Free Will and he is
allowing it to flourish however he is
also allowing Bad Things To possibly
still happen which is a conversation
Loki and Sylvie did have with each other
stating that even if they did manage to
save everything Earth is still a mess
but the whole point was they still
deserve a chance to try and that is what
Loki has given everybody until
incursions start happening and we know
they are because that is literally the
whole premise of Deadpool 3 and Avengers
Secret Wars yes the TVA can do their
best to try to get rid of King the
Conqueror variants but what if one of
those variants or many of them like
we've seen in Quantum Mania learn how to
exist outside of space and time well the
TVA monitors timelines and if they find
a bad King variant doing something they
go to that timeline and they simply
prune him but how do you go to something
that exists outside of space and time
how do you lock onto that coordinates
you can't it's like if they wanted to
find Loki they probably couldn't
speaking of if they tried to lock onto a
coordinance obviously they know they
could probably prune themselves and end
up in the void but if you were trying to
use a temp pad that wasn't he who
remains his temp pad to try and find the
Citadel at the end of time you couldn't
because there is no coordinates because
it doesn't exist in space that is most
likely where these other evil variants
of Kang that we saw in Quantum Mania
post credit scene are right now they
have mastered time travel because that's
what Kang the conquerer does so they're
outside of time and space so Loki has
given everybody Free Will and it's an
amazing story arc for him because it's
essentially a complete opposite version
of who we met in the first Thor and
Avengers film instead of making
everybody else kneel essentially he is
kneeling for everybody else to be able
to have free will that is until Secret
Wars we'll have to wait and see what
happens there but give us your best
theory of what's going to happen with
Loki in Avengers Secret Wars and let us
know how you feel about Loki's story arc
in the MCU drop your thoughts and
comments down below please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos you can find us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof
woof